the jurogan experience we were getting
like major athletes like major athletes
and i remember i interviewed um uh
wyatt chris weidman and he was fighting
um
uh he wasn't fighting the other guy uh
the anderson silva
no machida i can't remember luke
rockhold
it might have been when he was fighting
luke rockwell i can't remember um
what year this was about 2015. was he
the champ
he was the champ so the odds are it's
either vitor
leoto machida vidor it was vidor he was
fighting vador oh
and it was the first time i'd like sat
down with like
you know guys who were trained fighters
and the calm
it's just like a calm and a piece that
like i was trying to put my finger in
like what is that calm
and then i realized like if like i'm in
i get insecure you know but
you know i'm like got nervousness and a
lot of that is because
i always in a situation know there's pro
a probability that i could get [ __ ] up
but if i walked around and i knew that
99.7
of the people i could [ __ ] up i'd be
calm
well chris weidman is calm like i would
be calm if i was hanging out with 10
year old girls
and they were trying to tell me how the
world works and i'd be like that's cute
let me tell you how the world really
works yeah it's like that yeah
especially when he was the champ yeah i
mean when he was the champ first of all
when chris weidman was coming up and the
limitations of chris weidman
legitimately are the limitations of the
human body
because his body started to break he
started to
he had knee problems and neck problems
and back problems but
the limitations of his mind were
limitless it was there's a lot of these
guys like and a lot of them are
wrestlers
because i think wrestlers have the
strongest brains because the strongest
minds the strongest determination
because that sport is so [ __ ] brutal
but these great wrestlers who get into
fighting like chris weidman
and cain velasquez was another one the
limitations of came alaska's were the
limitations of his body because he
started getting
shoulder surgery and back surgery and
knee surgery
and then it all started falling apart
but when he was at his peak
chris weidman was a [ __ ] man
strong not just but the mind too
it's not it's not just the body his body
was surely strong but his mind was just
unbreakable
he would break guys you know and and
kane was the same way
kane was a guy who broke guys he break
them because i
i really firmly believe this this day
that wrestlers
because there's no go like i had jordan
burrows on the other day
he's a wrestler right olympic gold
medalist four-time world champion
stud of a human being and when you talk
to him you realize like
he's just so exceptional in every way
and one of the reasons why he's so
exceptional is because wrestling has
no glory like the people that get into
wrestling they do it
because it's the pursuit it's not
it's not like a bentley and a mansion
and
watches and rings and all that [ __ ]
like the the
the glory is in victory it's in the
pursuit and also
in victory in the most difficult of
circumstances which is like
amateur high level world-class wrestling
like those
it's so [ __ ] hard so the guys like
chris weidman the guys like jordan
burrows the guys like king velazquez
guys who excel in wrestling there's a
mindset that they have that's uh it's so
interesting to be around them
because they're they're because they are
that calm they have that
that there's a there's a level that
they've reached
that very few human beings outside of
wrestlers ever reached
that's fascinating do you think that's
changing now because they do have an
outlet with mma which is great like they
can go pro
and become rich and kind of famous some
of them but
you know like jordan burroughs doesn't
have any interest in in fighting
i mean especially his wife doesn't want
him to fight because he he does make
good money
wrestling just has an ambassador to
wrestling but i don't think
i don't think they go fall into the same
pitfalls that a lot of the other
uh fighters fall into you know like a
lot of them
they just uh they get into fame and
glory and all that [ __ ] and
wideman never really got into that he
was just into smashing people yeah
smashing yeah just just smashing people
like khabib i'm gonna smash your boy
he's the perfect example khabib's the
perfect example the guy drives a toyota
yeah okay he's worth
[ __ ] millions of dollars he's the
most dominant fighter in any weight
class in the history of the sport
and he is as calm and as humble as can
be while also
being incredibly confident yeah yeah and
super religious yeah doesn't drink
doesn't smoke doesn't party doesn't do
anything
it's just dedicated to smashing people
i'm gonna smash your boy right i'm gonna
smash your boy
when he said that i'm gonna smash your
somebody said to me that's like samuel
jackson in pulp fiction you're like oh
[ __ ]
it's greater because it's not fake right
and he did it yeah and he did smash him
and he you know what the
the best the scariest thing that he ever
said he goes i want to change his face
yeah yeah i want to change his face
how much is the mental bat did like
conor when he fought conor it was like
opposites going against each other like
that ultra humility versus that like
you know absolute boastful like do you
think connor knew before
just no like do you think he went he's
gonna win and look he
he won a round with khabib he won the
third round and that's probably the only
round that could be lost in his entire
career like
there's an argument that maybe you lost
one or two rounds earlier that are real
close
but i mean he's he's 29-0 you have to
understand how insane that is and then
you have to understand the weight class
he's in
he's in the 155 pound weight class which
is arguably the most competitive in the
history of the sport
right there's like the arguments are
like 45-55
and maybe 70 or the most competitive uh
weight classes ever
and he's the the most dominant guy ever
in the most competitive weight class
yeah i mean he's a monster he's a beast
man
you're in that weight class and you know
you got to fight him you're like yeah
do you think you question everything
about yourself yeah do you think
wrestlers
on to that level are have an advantage
in mma like because you just eventually
going to get your hands on a guy
yeah well that's what he has an
advantage i mean he when he wrestles
guys when he grabs them you could see
the look in their face
like oh my god this is different it's
like an anaconda got you just different
well look at his last guy that he fought
is justin gaichi who's a [ __ ] killer
right
smashes tony ferguson smashes edson
barboza i mean he's a [ __ ] beast and
a really good wrestler too but when
khabib got a hold of him
every time just drags him to the ground
and almost submitted him at the end of
the first round and then submitted him
in the second round
he said he wanted it submit he didn't
want to hurt him
do you think that was true yeah he said
like i didn't want to do it that way
because his parents were there
well that's some [ __ ] ill [ __ ] to say
like i'll just wait till next round do
it a little softer
well they were friends justin actually
they have the same manager
and justin actually helped him cut
weight earlier in his career because
cutting weight
is uh i don't know have you ever spent
some time in the sauna
i have i went i did some shows in sweden
yeah yeah there's a
there's a moment in the sauna that comes
around
like minute 13 fourteen especially if
it's like a hot
minute three for me when you start
looking around you're like you look at
your wash and you're like
[ __ ] like how do i do this i wanna get
out
now and you don't you don't get out you
stay in
and so it's like you need support and
like a lot of times the guys will have
guys cut weight with them
and they'll come and sit with you and
give you support because like as much as
khabib is like his mind is a a [ __ ]
a vault a bank vault i mean his mind is
impenetrable
even a man like him we will use
encouragement from other people and use
support and love and friendship from
other people
and justin helped him cut weight wow and
i think they were he was they had a bond
because of that
so when he fought conor he wanted to
change his face he wanted to smash
smash your boy with gaijin he's just
like i'm gonna beat him and i'm gonna
beat him the way
i would beat a friend it's like you're
beating up your brother yeah like you go
like
you know i'm gonna hurt you but not
you're my brother so it's gonna like i'm
gonna do it so you can
he he went to submissions faster than he
has in any other
fight he's ever had god he's not good
he's not good he almost caught
he fought with a broken toe too by the
way wow snapped like he took a
they showed an x-ray of his toe after
the fight he broke his toe
in training right and a lot of guys
would have pulled out of that fight if
you look
at the fight i watched it yesterday
actually while i was working out he had
his toes taped together
right that's it that's the brace right
that's the cast right
a little piece of tape connecting his
toes when you break your toe that's all
you can do right is really just tape it
up
he's an extraordinary human being and uh
it's his mind i mean his body obviously
is uh
ridiculous too but his body is
ridiculous because of his mind
yeah you know and he just comes from a
place that like
you know what did joe dimaggio say like
uh and so rich rich guys can't make the
big leagues he comes from a place that
probably like getting in the octagon is
like the easiest thing he's done in his
entire life
i mean those videos of him as a kid
wrestling
i mean it's like you got you got to get
in the ring with him you're going like
how can i grapple better than a
bear catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience